PROFESSOR: Last time,
we talked about the
representation of linear
time-invariant systems through
the convolution sum in the
discrete-time case and the
convolution integral in the
continuous-time case.
Now, although the derivation
was relatively
straightforward, in fact, the
result is really kind of
amazing because what it tells
us is that for linear
time-invariant systems, if we
know the response of the
system to a single impulse at
t = 0, or in fact, at any
other time, then we can
determine from that its
response to an arbitrary input
through the use of
convolution.
Furthermore, what we'll see as
the course develops is that,
in fact, the class of linear
time-invariant systems is a
very rich class.
There are lots of systems
that have that property.
And in addition, there are
lots of very interesting
things that you can do with
linear time-invariant systems.
In today's lecture, what I'd
like to begin with is focusing
on convolution as an algebraic
operation.
And we'll see that it has a
number of algebraic properties
that in turn have important
implications for linear
time-invariant systems.
Then we'll turn to a discussion
of what the
characterization of linear
time-invariant systems through
convolution implies, in terms
of the relationship, of
various other system properties
to the impulse response.
Let me begin by reminding you
of the basic result that we
developed last time, which
is the convolution sum in
discrete time, as I indicate
here, and the convolution
integral in continuous time.
And what the convolution sum,
or the convolution integral,
tells us is how to relate the
output to the input and to the
system impulse response.
And the expression looks
basically the same in
continuous time and
discrete time.
And I remind you also that we
talked about a graphical
interpretation, where
essentially, to graphically
interpret convolution required,
or was developed, in
terms of taking the system
impulse response, flipping it,
sliding it past the input, and
positioned appropriately,
depending on the value of the
independent variable for which
we're computing the convolution,
and then
multiplying and summing in the
discrete-time case, or
integrating in the
continuous-time case.
Now convolution, as an algebraic
operation, has a
number of important
properties.
One of the properties of
convolution is that it is what
is referred to as commutative.
Commutative means that we can
think either of convolving x
with h, or h with x, and the
order in which that's done
doesn't affect the
output result.
So summarized here is what the
commutative operation is in
discrete time, or in
continuous time.
And it says, as I just
indicated, that x[n]
convolved with h[n]
is equal to h[n]
convolved with x[n].
Or the same, of course,
in continuous time.
And in fact, in the lecture
last time, we worked an
example where we had, in
discrete time, an impulse
response, which was an
exponential, and an input,
which is a unit step.
And in the text, what you'll
find is the same example
worked, except in that case, the
input is the exponential.
And the system impulse
response is the step.
And that corresponds to the
example in the text, which is
example 3.1.
And what happens in that example
is that, in fact, what
you'll see is that the same
result occurs in example 3.1
as we generated in
the lecture.
And there's a similar comparison
in continuous time.
This example was worked
in lecture.
And this example is worked
in the text.
In other words, the text works
the example where the system
impulse response
is a unit step.
And the input is
an exponential.
All right, now the commutative
property, as I said, tells us
that the order in which we do
convolution doesn't affect the
result of the convolution.
The same is true for
continuous time
and discrete time.
And in fact, for the other
algebraic properties that I'll
talk about, the results are
exactly the same for
continuous time and
discrete time.
So in fact, what we can do is
drop the independent variable
as an argument so that we
suppress any kind of
difference between continuous
and discrete time.
And suppressing the independent
variable, we then
state the commutative property
as I've rewritten it here.
Just x convolved with h equals
h convolved with x.
The same in continuous time
and discrete time.
Now, the derivation of the
commutative property is, more
or less, some algebra
which you can follow
through in the book.
It involves some changes
of variables and some
things of that sort.
What I'd like to focus on with
that and other properties is
not the derivation, which you
can see in the text, but
rather the interpretation.
So we have the commutative
property, and now there are
two other important algebraic
properties.
One being what is referred to
as the associative property,
which tells us that if we have x
convolved with the result of
convolving h1 with h2, that's
exactly the same as x
convolved with h1, and that
result convolved with h2.
And what this permits is for
us to write, for example, x
convolved with h1 convolved with
h2 without any ambiguity
because it doesn't matter from
the associative property how
we group the terms together.
The third important property is
what is referred to as the
distributive property, namely
the fact that convolution
distributes over addition.
And what I mean by that is what
I've indicated here on
the slide: that if I think of x
convolved with the sum of h1
and h2, that's identical to
first convolving x with h1,
also convolving x with h2, and
then adding the two together.
And that result will be the
same as this result.
So convolution is commutative,
associative, and it
distributes over addition.
Three very important algebraic
properties.
And by the way, there are other
algebraic operations
that have that same property.
For example, multiplication
of numbers is likewise
commutative, associative,
and distributive.
Now let's look at what these
three properties imply
specifically for linear
time-invariant systems.
And as we'll see, the
implications are both very
interesting and very
important.
Let's begin with the commutative
property.
And consider, in particular,
a system with an impulse
response h.
And I represent that by simply
writing the h inside the box.
An input x and an output,
then, which is x * h.
Now, since this operation is
commutative, I can write
instead of x * h, I
can write h * x.
And that would correspond to a
system with impulse response
x, and input h, and
output then h * x.
So the commutative property
tells us that for a linear
time-invariant system, the
system output is independent
of which function we call the
input and which function we
call the impulse response.
Kind of amazing actually.
We can interchange the role of
input and impulse response.
And from an output point of
view, the output or the system
doesn't care.
Now furthermore, if we combine
the commutative property with
the associative property,
we get another
very interesting result.
Namely that if we have two
linear time-invariant systems
in cascade, the overall system
is independent of the order in
which they're cascaded.
And in fact, in either case, the
cascade can be collapsed
into a single system.
To see this, let's first
consider the cascade of two
systems, one with impulse
response h1, the other with
impulse response h2.
And the output of the first
system is then x * h1.
And then that is the input
to the second system.
And so the output of that is
that result convolved with h2.
So this is the result of
cascading the two.
And now we can use the
associative property to
rewrite this as x * (h1
* h2), where we group
these two terms together.
And so using the associative
property, we now can collapse
that into a single system with
an input, which is x, and
impulse response, which
is h1 * h2.
And the output is then x
convolved with the result of
those two convolved.
Next, we can apply the
commutative property.
And the commutative property
says we could write this
impulse response that way, or
we could write it this way.
And since convolution is
commutative, the resulting
output will be exactly
the same.
And so these resulting outputs
will be exactly the same.
And now, once again we can use
the associative property to
group these two terms
together.
And x * h2 corresponds to
putting x first through the
system h2 and then that output
through the system h1.
And so finally applying the
associative property again, as
I just outlined, we can expand
that system back into two
systems in cascade with h2
first and h1 second,
OK, well that involves a certain
amount of algebraic
manipulation.
And that is not the algebraic
manipulation that is important.
It's the result that
it's important.
And what the result says, to
reiterate, is if I have two
linear time-invariant systems in
cascade, I can cascade them
in any order, and the
result is the same.
Now you might think, well gee,
maybe that actually applies to
systems in general, whether
you put them
this way or that way.
But in fact, as we talked
about last time, and I
illustrated with an example, in
general, if the systems are
not linear and time-invariant,
then the order in which
they're cascaded is important
to the interpretation of the
overall system.
For example, if one system took
the square root and the
other system doubled the input,
taking the square root
and then doubling gives us a
different answer than doubling
first and then taking
the square root.
And of course, one can construct
much more elaborate
examples than that.
So it's a property very
particular to linear
time-invariant systems.
And also one that we will
exploit many, many times as we
go through this material.
The final property related to an
interconnection of systems
that I want to just indicate
develops out of the
distributive property.
And what it applies to is
an interpretation of the
interconnection of systems
in parallel.
Recall that the parallel
combination of systems
corresponds, as I indicate here,
to a system in which we
simultaneously feed the input
into h1 and h2, these
representing the impulse
responses.
And then, the outputs
are summed to
form the overall output.
And using the fact that
convolution distributes over
addition, we can rewrite
this as x * (h1 + h2).
And when we do that then, we
can recognize this as the
output of a system with input x
and impulse response, which
is the sum of these two
impulse responses.
So for linear time-invariant
systems in parallel, we can,
if we choose, replace that
interconnection by a single
system whose impulse response
is simply the sum of those
impulse responses.
OK, now we have this very
powerful representation for
linear time-invariant systems
in terms of convolution.
And we've seen so far in this
lecture how convolution and
the representation through the
impulse response leads to some
important implications for
system interconnections.
What I'd like to turn to now
are other system properties
and see how, for linear
time-invariant systems in
particular, other system
properties can be associated
with particular properties or
characteristics of the system
impulse response.
And what we'll talk about are
a variety of properties.
We'll talk about the issue of
memory, we'll talk about the
issue of invertibility, and
we'll talk about the issue of
causality and also stability.
Well, let's begin with
the issue of memory.
And the question now is what are
the implications for the
system impulse response for a
linear time-invariant system?
Remember that we're always
imposing that on the system.
What are the implications on
the impulse response if the
system does or does
not have memory?
Well, we can answer
that by looking at
the convolution property.
And we have here, as a reminder,
the convolution
integral, which tells us how
x(tau) and h(t - tau) are
combined to give us y(t).
And what I've illustrated
above is a
general kind of example.
Here is x(tau).
Here is h(t - tau).
And to compute the output at
any time t, we would take
these two, multiply them
together, and integrate from
-infinity to +infinity.
So the question then is what
can we say about h(t), the
impulse response in order to
guarantee, let's say, that the
output depends only on
the input at time t.
Well, it's pretty much obvious
from looking at the graphs.
If we only want the output to
depend on x(tau) at tau = t,
then h(t - tau) better be
non-zero only at tau = t.
And so the implication then is
that for the system to be
memoryless, what we require is
that h(t - tau) be non-zero
only at tau = t.
So we want the impulse response
to be non-zero at
only one point.
We want it to contribute
something after we multiply
and go through an integral.
And in effect, what that says is
the only thing that it can
be and meet all those
conditions is a scaled impulse.
So if the system is to be
memoryless, then that requires
that the impulse response
be a scaled impulse.
Any other impulse response then,
in essence, requires
that the system have memory,
or implies that the system
have memory.
So for the continuous-time case
then, memoryless would
correspond only to the impulse
response being proportional to
an impulse.
And in the discrete-time case,
a similar statement, in which
case, the output is just
proportional to the input,
again either in the
continuous-time or in the
discrete-time case.
All right.
Now we can turn our attention
to the issue of system
invertibility.
And recall that what is meant by
invertibility of a system,
or the inverse of a system.
The inverse of a system is a
system, which when we cascade
it with the one that we're
inquiring about, the overall
cascade is the identity
system.
In other words, the output
is equal to the input.
So let's consider a system
with impulse
response h, input is x.
And let's say that the impulse
response of the inverse system
is h_i, and the output is y.
Then, the output of this system
is x * (h * h_i).
And we want this to come
out equal to x.
And what that requires than is
that this convolution just
simply be equal to an impulse,
either in the discrete-time
case or in the continuous-time
case.
And under those conditions
then, h_i is equal to the
inverse of h.
Notationally, by the way, it's
often convenient to write
instead of h_i as the impulse
response of the inverse,
you'll find it convenient often
and more typical to
write as the inverse, instead
of h_i, h^(-1).
And we mean by that the inverse
impulse response.
And one has to be careful not
to misinterpret this as the
reciprocal of h(t) or h(n).
What's meant in this notation
is the inverse system.
Now, if h_i is the inverse of
h, is h the inverse of h_i?
Well, it seems like that ought
to be plausible or perhaps
make sense.
The question, if you believe
that the answer is yes, is
how, in fact, do you
verify that?
And I'll leave it to you
to think about it.
The answer is yes,
that if h_i is the inverse
of h, then h is
the inverse of h_i.
And the key to showing that is
to exploit the fact that when
we take these systems and
cascade them, we can cascade
them in either order.
All right now let's turn to
another system property, the
property of stability.
And again, we can tie that
property directly to issues
related, in particular, to the
system impulse response.
Now, stability is defined as
we've chosen to define it and
as I've defined it previously,
as bounded-input
bounded-output stability.
In other words, for every
bounded input
is a bounded output.
What you can show--
and I won't go through the
algebra here; it's gone
through in the book--
is that a necessary and
sufficient condition for a
linear time-invariant system
to be stable in the
bounded-input bounded-output
sense is that the impulse
response be what is referred
to as absolutely summable.
In other words, if you take the
absolute values and sum
them over infinite limits,
that's finite.
Or in the continuous-time
case, that the impulse
response is absolutely
integrable.
In other words, if you take the
absolute values of h(t)
and integrate, that's finite.
And under those conditions,
the system is stable.
If those conditions are
violated, then for sure, as
you'll see in the text, the
system is unstable.
So stability can also
be tied to the
system impulse response.
Now, the next property that I
want to talk about is the
property of causality.
And before I do, what I'd like
to do is introduce a
peripheral result that
we'll then use--
when we talked about
causality--
namely what's referred to as the
zero input response of a
linear system.
The basic result, which is a
very interesting and useful
one, is that for a
linear system--
and in fact, it's whether it's
time-invariant or not, that
this applies--
if you put nothing into it,
you get nothing out of it.
So if we have an input x(t)
which is 0 for all t, and if
the output of that system is
y(t), if the input is 0 for
all time, then the output
likewise is 0 for all time.
That's true for continuous time,
and it's also true for
discrete time.
And in fact, to show that
result is pretty much
straightforward.
We could do it either by using
convolution, which would, of
course, be associated with
linearity and time invariance.
But in fact, we can show that
property relatively easily by
simply using the fact that, for
a linear system, what we
know is that if we have an
input x(t) with an output
y(t), then if we scale the
input, then the output scales
accordingly.
Well, we can simply choose, as
the scale factor, a = 0.
And if we do that, it
says put nothing in,
you get nothing out.
And what we'll see is that has
some important implications in
terms of causality.
It's important, though, while
we're on it, to stress that
not every system, obviously,
has that property.
That if you put nothing in,
you get nothing out.
A simple example is, let's say,
a battery, let's say not
connected to anything.
The output is six volts no
matter what the input is.
And it of course then doesn't
have this zero response to a
zero input.
It's very particular
to linear systems.
All right, well now let's see
what this means for causality.
To remind you, causality says,
in effect, that the system
can't anticipate the input.
That's what, basically,
causality means.
When we talked about it
previously, we defined it in a
variety of ways, one of which
was the statement that if two
inputs are identical up until
some time, then the outputs
must be identical up until
the same time.
The reason, kind of intuitively,
is that if the
system is causal--
so it can't anticipate
the future--
it can't anticipate whether
these two identical inputs are
sometime later going to change
from each other or not.
So causality, in general, is
simply this statement, either
continuous-time or
discrete-time.
And now, so let's look
at what that means
for a linear system.
For a linear system, what that
corresponds to or could be
translated to is a statement
that says that if x(t) is 0,
for t less than t_0, then
y(t) must be 0 for t
less than t_0 also.
And so what that, in effect,
says, is that the system--
for a linear system to be
causal, it must have the
property sometimes referred to
as initial rest, meaning it
doesn't respond until there's
some input that happens.
That it's initially
at rest until the
input becomes non-zero.
Now, why is this true?
Why is this a consequence of
causality for linear systems?
Well, the reason is we know that
if we put nothing in, we
get nothing out.
If we have an input that's 0 for
t less than t_0, and the
system can't anticipate whether
that input is going to
change from 0 or not, then the
system must generate an output
that's 0 up until that time,
following the principle that
if two inputs are identical up
until some time, the outputs
must be identical up until
the same time.
So this basic result for linear
systems is essentially
a consequence of the statement
that for a linear system, zero
in gives us zero out.
Now, that tells us
how to interpret
causality for linear systems.
Now, let's proceed to linear
time-invariant systems.
And in fact, we can carry the
point one step further.
In particular, a necessary and
sufficient condition for
causality in the case of linear
time-invariant systems
is that the impulse response be
0, for t less than 0 in the
continuous-time case, or for
n less than 0 in the
discrete-time case.
So for linear time-invariant
systems, causality is
equivalent to the impulse
response being 0 up until t or
n equal to 0.
Now, to show this essentially
follows by first considering
why causality would imply
that this is true.
And that follows because of the
straightforward fact that
the impulse itself is
0 for t less than 0.
And what we saw before is that
for any linear system,
causality requires that if the
input is 0 up until some time,
the output must be 0 up
until the same time.
And so that's showing the
result in one direction.
To show the result in the other
direction, namely to
show that if, in fact, the
impulse response satisfies
that condition, then the
system is causal.
While I won't work through it
in detail, it essentially
boils down to recognizing that
in the convolution sum, or in
the convolution integral, if,
in fact, that condition is
satisfied on the impulse
response, then the upper limit
on the sum, in the
discrete-time
case, changes to n.
And in the continuous-time
case, changes to t.
And that, in effect, says that
values of the input only from
-infinity up to time n are
used in computing y[n].
And a similar kind
of result for the
continuous-time case y(t).
OK, so we've seen how the
impulse response, or rather
how certain system properties
in the linear time-invariant
case can, be converted into
various requirements on the
impulse response of a linear
time-invariant system, the
impulse response being a
complete characterization.
Let's look at some particular
examples just to kind of
cement the ideas further.
And let's begin with a system
that you've seen previously,
which is an accumulator.
An accumulator, as you recall,
has an output y[n], which is
the accumulated value of the
input from -infinity up to n.
Now, you've seen in the impulse
in a previous lecture,
or rather in the video course
manual for a previous lecture,
that an accumulator is a linear
time-invariant system.
And in fact, its impulse
response is the accumulated
values of an impulse.
Namely, the impulse response
is equal to a step.
So what we want to answer is,
knowing what that impulse
response is, what some
properties are of the
accumulator.
And let's first ask
about memory.
Well, we recognize that the
impulse response is not simply
an impulse.
In fact, it's a step.
And so this implies what?
Well, it implies that the
system has memory.
Second, the impulse response
is 0 for n less than 0.
That implies that the
system is causal.
And finally, if we look at the
sum of the absolute values of
the impulse response
from -infinity to
+infinity, this is a step.
If we accumulate those values
over infinite limits, then
that in fact comes out
to be infinite.
And so what that implies, then,
is that the accumulator
is not stable in the
bounded-input
bounded-output sense.
Now I want to turn to
some other systems.
But while we're on the
accumulator, I just want to
draw your attention to the fact,
which will kind of come
up in a variety of ways again
later, that we can rewrite the
equation for an accumulator,
the difference equation, by
recognizing that we could, in
fact, write the output as the
accumulated values up to
time n - 1 and then
add on the last value.
And in fact, if we do that, this
corresponds to y[n-1].
And so we could rewrite this
difference equation as y[n]
= y[n-1]
+ x[n].
So the output is the
previously-computed output
plus the input.
Expressed that way, what that
corresponds to is what is
called a recursive difference
equation.
And different equations will
be a topic of considerable
emphasis in the next lecture.
Now, does an accumulator
have an inverse?
Well, the answer is,
in fact, yes.
And let's look at what the
inverse of the accumulator is.
The impulse response of the
accumulator is a step.
To inquire about its inverse,
we inquire about whether
there's a system, which when
we cascade the accumulator
with that system, which I'm
calling its inverse, we get an
impulse out.
Well, let's see.
The impulse response of the
accumulator is a step.
We want to put the step
into something
and get out an impulse.
And in fact, what you recall
from the lecture in which we
introduced steps and impulses,
the impulse is, in fact, the
first difference of
the units step.
So we have a difference equation
that describes for us
how the impulse is related
to the step.
And so if this system does this,
the output will be that,
an impulse.
And so if we think of x_2[n]
as the input and y_2[n]
as the output, then the
difference equation for the
inverse system is what
I've indicated here.
And if we want to look at the
impulse response of that, we
can then inquire as to what
the response is with an
impulse in.
And what develops in a
straightforward way then is
delta[n], which is our impulse
input, minus delta[n-1]
is equal to the impulse
response
of the inverse system.
So I'll write that
as h^(-1)[n]
(h-inverse of n).
Now, we have then that the
accumulator has an inverse.
And this is the inverse.
And you can examine issues
of memory, stability,
causality, et cetera.
What you'll find is that the
system has memory, the inverse
accumulator.
It's stable, and it's causal.
And it's interesting to note, by
the way, that although the
accumulator was an unstable
system, the inverse of the
accumulator is a
stable system.
In general, if the system is
stable, its inverse does not
have to be stable
or vice versa.
And the same thing
with causality.
OK now, there are a number of
other examples, which, of
course, we could discuss.
And let me just quickly point
to one example, which is a
difference equation, as
I've indicated here.
And as we'll talk about in
more detail in our next
lecture, where we'll get
involved in a fairly detailed
discussion of linear
constant-coefficient
difference and differential
equations, this falls into
that category.
And under the imposition of
what's referred to as initial
rest, which corresponds to the
response being 0 up until the
time that the input becomes
non-zero, the impulse response
is a^n times u[n].
And something that you'll be
asked to think about in the
video course manual is whether
that system has memory,
whether it's causal, and
whether it's stable.
And likewise, for a linear
constant coefficient
differential equation, the
specific one that I've
indicated here, under the
assumption of initial rest,
the impulse response is
e^(-2t) times u(t).
And in the video course manual
again, you'll be asked to
examine whether the system has
memory, whether it's causal,
and whether it's stable.
OK well, as I've indicated, in
the next lecture we'll return
to a much more detailed
discussion of linear
constant-coefficient
differential
and difference equations.
Now, what I'd like to finally do
in this lecture is use the
notion of convolution in a much
different way to help us
with a problem that I
alluded to earlier.
In particular, the issue of how
to deal with some of the
mathematical difficulties
associated with
impulses and steps.
Now, let me begin by
illustrating kind of what the
problem is and an example of the
kind of paradox that you
sort of run into when dealing
with impulse functions and
step functions.
Let's consider, first of all,
a system, which is the
identity system.
And so the output is, of course,
equal to the input.
And again, we can talk about
that either in continuous time
or in discrete time.
Well, we know that the function
that you convolve
with a signal to retain the
signal is an impulse.
And so that means that the
impulse response of an
identity system is an impulse.
Makes logical sense.
Furthermore, if I take two
identity systems and cascade
them, I put in an input, get
the same thing out of the
first system.
That goes into the
second system.
Get the same thing out
of the second.
In other words, if I have two
identity systems in cascade,
the cascade, likewise, is
an identity system.
In other words, this
overall system is
also an identity system.
And the implication there is
that the impulse response of
this is an impulse.
The impulse response of
And the convolution of those
two is also an impulse.
So for continuous time, we
require, then, that an impulse
convolved with itself
is an impulse.
And the same thing for
discrete time.
Now, in discrete time, we don't
have any particular
problem with that.
If you think about convolving
these together, it's a
straightforward mathematical
operation since the impulse in
discrete time is very
nicely defined.
However, in continuous time, we
have to be somewhat careful
about the definition of the
impulse because it was the
derivative of a step.
A step has a discontinuity.
You can't really differentiate
at a discontinuity.
And the way that we dealt with
that was to expand out the
discontinuity so that it had
some finite time region in
which it happened.
When we did that, we ended up
with a definition for the
impulse, which was the
limiting form of this
function, which is a rectangle
of width Delta, and height 1 /
Delta, and an area equal to 1.
Now, if we think of convolving
this signal with itself, the
impulse being the limiting
form of this, then the
convolution of this with itself
is a triangle of width
2 Delta, height 1 /
Delta, and area 1.
In other words, this triangular
function is this
approximation delta_Delta(t)
convolved with delta_Delta(t).
And since the limit of this
would correspond to the
impulse response of the identity
system convolved with
itself, the implication is that
not only should the top
function, this one, correspond
in its limiting form to an
impulse, but also this should
correspond in its limiting
form to an impulse.
So one could wonder well,
what is an impulse?
Is it this one in the limit?
Or is it this one
in the limit?
Now, beyond that-- so kind of
what this suggests is that in
the limiting form, you kind of
run into a contradiction
unless you don't try to
distinguish between this
rectangle and the triangle.
Things get even worse when you
think about what happens when
you put an impulse into
a differentiator.
And a differentiator is a very
commonly occurring system.
In particular, suppose we had a
system for which the output
was the derivative
of the input.
So if we put in x(t), we
got out dx(t) / dt.
If I put in an impulse, or if
I talked about the impulse
response, what is that?
And of course, the problem is
that if you think that the
impulse itself is very badly
behaved, then what about its
derivative, which is not only
infinitely big, but there's a
positive-going one, and a
negative-going one, and the
difference between there
has some area.
And you end up in a
lot of difficulty.
Well, the way around this,
formally, is through a set of
mathematics referred to as
generalized functions.
We won't be quite that formal.
But I'd like to, at least,
suggest what the essence of
that formality is.
And it really helps us in
interpreting the impulses in
steps and functions
of that type.
And what it is is an operational
definition of
steps, impulses, and their
derivatives in
the following sense.
Usually when we talk about a
function, we talk about what
the value of the function is
at any instant of time.
And of course, the trouble
with an impulse is it's
infinitely big, in zero width,
and has some area, et cetera.
What we can turn to is what is
referred to as an operational
definition where the operational
definition is
related not to what the impulse
is, but to what the
impulse does under the operation
of convolution.
So what is an impulse?
An impulse is something,
which under
convolution, retains the function.
And that then can serve as a
definition of the impulse.
Well, let's see where
that gets us.
Suppose that we now want to talk
about the derivative of
the impulse.
Well, what we ask about is
what it is operationally.
And so if we have a system,
which is a differentiator, and
we inquire about its impulse
response, which let's say we
define notationally as u_1(t).
What's important about this
function u_1(t) is not what it
is at each value of time
but what it does under
convolution.
What does it do under
convolution?
Well, the output of the
differentiator is the
convolution of the input with
the impulse response.
And so what u_1(t) does under
convolution is to
differentiate.
And that is the operational
definition.
And now, of course, we can
think of extending that.
Not only would we want to think
about differentiating an
impulse, but we would also
want to think about
differentiating the derivative
of an impulse.
We'll define that as
a function u_2(t).
u_2(t)--
because we have this impulse
response convolved with this
one is u_1(t) * u_1(t).
And what is u_2(t)
operationally?
It is the operation such that
when you convolve that with
x(t), what you get is the
second derivative.
OK now, we can carry this
further and, in fact, talk
about the result of convolving
u_1(t) with itself more times.
In fact, if we think of the
convulution of u_1(t) with
itself k times, then
logically we would
define that as u_k(t).
Again, we would interpret
that operationally.
And the operational definition
is through convolution, where
this corresponds to u_k(t) being
the impulse response of
k differentiators in cascade.
So what is the operational
definition?
Well, it's simply that x(t)
* u_k(t) is the k
derivative of x(t).
And this now gives us a set
of what are referred to as
singularity functions.
Very badly behaved
mathematically in a sense, but
as we've seen, reasonably well
defined under an operational
definition.
With k = 0, incidentally, that's
the same as what we
have referred to previously
as the impulse.
So with k 0, that's
just delta(t).
Now to be complete, we can also
go the other way and talk
about the impulse response of
a string of integrators
instead of a string of
differentiators.
Of course, the impulse
response of a single
integrator is a unit step.
Two integrators together
is the integral of a
unit step, et cetera.
And that, likewise, corresponds
to a set of what
are called singularity
functions.
In particular, if I take a
string of m integrators in
cascade, then the impulse
response of that is denoted as
u sub minus m of t.
And for example, with a single
integrator, u sub minus 1 of t
corresponds to our unit step as
we talked about previously.
u sub minus 2 of t corresponds
to a unit ramp, et cetera.
And there is, in fact, a reason
for choosing negative
values of the argument when
going in one direction near
integration as compared with
positive values of the
argument when going in the
other direction, namely
differentiation.
In particular, we know that with
u sub minus m of t, the
operational definition is the
mth running integral.
And likewise, u_k(t)--
so with a positive
sub script--
has an operational definition,
which is the derivative.
So it's the kth derivative
of x(t).
And partly as a consequence of
that, if we take u_k(t) and
convolve it with u_l(t), the
result is the singularity
function with the subscript,
which is the sum of k and l.
And that holds whether this
is positive values of the
subscript or negative values
of the subscript.
So just to summarize this last
discussion, we've used an
operational definition to talk
about derivatives of impulses
and integrals of impulses.
This led to a set of singularity
functions-- what
I've called singularity
functions--
of which the impulse and the
step are two examples.
But using an operational
definition through convolution
allows us to define, at least in
an operational sense, these
functions that otherwise
are very badly behaved.
OK now, in this lecture and
previous lectures, for the
most part, our discussion
has been about linear
time-invariant systems in
fairly general terms.
And we've seen a variety of
properties, representation
through convolution, and
properties as they can be
associated with the
impulse response.
In the next lecture, we'll turn
our attention to a very
important subclass of those
systems, namely systems that
are describable by linear
constant-coefficient
difference equations in the
discrete-time case, and linear
constant-coefficient
differential equations in the
continuous-time case.
Those classes, while not forming
all of the class of
linear time-invariant
systems, are a very
important sub class.
And we'll focus in on those
specifically next time.
Thank you.